un bonjour à tous nous vous proposons
cet après-midi d'écouter la discussion
générale sur une proposition de loi sur
l'application des normes
cette proposition a été déposée
conjointement par jean pierre sueur le
président socialiste de la commission
des lois
ici au sénat et la sénatrice jacqueline
gourault
ce texte fait suite aux états généraux
de la démocratie territoriale organisé
l'année dernière sous l'égide du
président du sénat et la proposition de
loi crée un conseil national
d'évaluation des normes applicables aux
collectivités territoriales voilà tout
de suite direction l'hémicycle l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion en
deuxième lecture la proposition de loi
portant création d'un conseil national
d'évaluation des normes applicables aux
collectivités territoriales et à leurs
établissements publics et de la
proposition de loi organique tendant à
joindre les avis rendus par le conseil
national d'évaluation des normes au
projet de loi relatif aux collectivités
territoriales et à leurs groupements
présenté par madame jacqueline gourault
et monsieur le président jean pierre
sueur
la conférence des présidents a décidé
que ces deux textes ferait l'objet d'une
discussion générale commune dans la
discussion générale commune la parole
est à madame anne marie escoffier
ministre chargé de la décentralisation
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur madame et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
s'il y a une proposition de loi dont
chacun aspire à ce qu'elle soit adoptée
dans les meilleurs conditions
c'est bien celle qui revient auprès de
vous cet après midi la simplification
des normes
la chasse aux normes inutile obsolète
coûteuse le refus de normes nouvelles
sans que viennent en contrepartie des
suppressions de normes tous marre et bon
sens
bur bon sens réclamé depuis longtemps
par l'ensemble des élus locaux sur qui
pèse une charge insupportable
voilà plusieurs années qu'un
rassemblement
vous avez été nombreux parlementaires à
vouloir trouver des voies de solution à
imaginer des dispositifs simplificateur
je ne peux passer sous silence ici les
initiatives prises par plusieurs d'entre
vous claude bellot eric doligé et plus
récemment
jacqueline gourault est le président de
la commission des lois jean pierre sueur
leur démarche
venez répondre à l'engagement pris par
le président de la république aux états
généraux de la démocratie locale
rappelez vous le 5 octobre 2012 il y a à
peine plus d'un an
on va peut-être fêter aujourd'hui ou
presque un anniversaire en premier
anniversaire donc l'engagement a été
pris par le président de la république
de tordre enfin le cou à la propension
qui est la nôtre de toujours imaginer
des contraintes pour nous sécuriser
parfois même contre l'improbable la
proposition de loi qui revient en
deuxième lecture auprès de vous cet
après midi et qui avait été voté à
l'unanimité vous vous en rappelez avec
une abstention le 28 janvier 2013
acheminé en même temps qu'était elle
or et le rapport de deux chasseurs de
normes
alain lambert et jean claude boulard qui
ont remis leur rapport le 26 mars 2013
et qu'intervenait successivement
plusieurs recommandations du premier
ministre recommandations de
simplification circulaire du 9 février
2013 d'interprétation facilitatrice
circulaire du 2 avril 2013 de
substitution d'une norme créé à une
norme supprimer sérieux derrière du 18
juillet 2013 consécutive à comité
interministériel de modernisation de
l'action publique la volonté de tous
gouvernement et parlementaires et de
simplifier simplifier ce qui au cours
des années s'est accumulée a pris un tel
en bon point qu'il n'entre même plus
dans son costume législatif alors
comment ne pas souscrire à ce long et
patient travail que vous avez construit
les uns les autres en l'enrichissant de
vos réflexions de votre expérience de
votre bon sens
le gouvernement y souscrit pour sa part
qui a choisi la voie droite
pour y parvenir la voie de l'efficacité
et de la rapidité que vous proposez avec
un texte qui a recueilli l'accord
unanime de vos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale le 19 septembre dernier un
accord sur un texte certes amendé mais
dans le droit fil de vos propres
recommandations et interventions un
texte qui revient vers vous porter à
votre initiative d'un conseil national
d'évaluation des normes dans le rôle est
bien celui d'un guetteur d'un veilleur
garant de l'application raisonnée des
contraintes qui s'imposent tous
collectivités locales et à leurs
établissements publics
un conseil national qui donne toute
initiative aux parlementaires et aux
élus locaux dans la diversité de la
représentation des territoires
un conseil national
consultés sur tous les sujets ayant un
impact de techniques et financiers sur
les collectivités et leurs
établissements publics que ces sujets
soit inscrit dans un projet de loi dans
un projet d'acte de l'union européenne
voir dans une proposition de loi en
plein accord avec ma collègue valérie
fourneyron ministre des sports le
gouvernement a fait adopter un
amendement d'articulation entre le
conseil national d'évaluation des normes
et la commission d'examen des règlements
fédéraux applicable aux équipements
sportifs afin d'améliorer un dispositif
insuffisamment encadrée je ne saurais
terminer cette brève intervention sans
relever la perspicacité des auteurs de
cette proposition qui ont indiqué à
l'issue des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale l'imperfection qu'il fallait
corriger de la possibilité qu'ils
auraient été laissés au gouvernement de
ne pas consulter le conseil national
d'évaluation des normes si les projets
de loi sur les projets de lois
imperfections corrigé dans la
proposition de loi organique examiné
conjointement le gouvernement fins ces
deux propositions qui conforte sa
détermination à réduire la logorrhée
normative à couper les branches de
l'arbre à palabres ne peut que saluer le
travail de fond travail constructif
auquel vous vous êtes unanimement
atteler il salue un texte dont il est
sûr qu'il restera comme un texte
fondateur de bon sens d'équilibré entre
les indispensables normes protectrice du
citoyen des collectivités territoriales
et celle excessive je ferai mienne la
conclusion des deux auteurs du rapport
que j'évoquais il ya quelques minutes
alain lambert et jean claude boulard en
disant que ce texte secouent notre droit
pour nous redonner les droit d'agir
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur alain richard rapporteur de la
commission des lois
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous repartons pour
cette seconde lecture qui je l'espère
sera conclusive d'une excellente base
puisque nous avons nous mêmes au sénat
en première lecture bien compléter et
améliorer perfectionner ce projet de loi
cette proposition de loi
travailler au départ par nos collègues
amis madame gourou président sueur eux
mêmes en réalité porteur d'une
recommandation 'vente' venus des états
généraux nous avions donc déjà ce large
accord est un travail qui était assez
bien avancé et noémie de l'assemblée
avec la ministre a fait remarquer cette
petite hésitation sur le lieu
d'insertion du texte nous renvoie un
texte dans lequel qu'ils ont adopté à
l'unanimité donc nous sommes dans de
bonnes conditions préparatoires et avec
quelques modifications que nous pouvons
sans difficulté à prouver je vais
voulait résumer brièvement l'assemblée a
fait évoluer à peu près dans le même
cadre que le nôtre le la composition du
conseil national avec un équilibre entre
les différents niveaux de collectivités
représentées en dehors des représentants
de l'état soit représentant de
l'exécutif soit parlementaire des du
fait que nous nous avons pu nous
concerter avec le rapporteur de
l'assemblée de manière à arriver le plus
possible à l'est position commune ils
ont bien voulu prévoir que bien entendu
ces représentants des collectivités
territoriales comporterait parmi eux un
certain nombre de représentants des
exécutifs soit des présidents
président de région où mary
maire-adjoint mais avec une définition
suffisamment large pour ne pas
comprendre le conseil national à
n'accueillir que des élus des as déjà
fort chargé
demanda donc je pense que nous aurons de
bonnes conditions de disponibilité des
nouveaux membres du conseil national
le rapporteur a par ailleurs fait
adopter le souhait enfin l'obligation
exactement que la composition du conseil
national soit paritaire et il a proposé
une durée de mandat de trois ans de
manière à ce que en fonction du
déroulement du mandat électif d
intéresser des gens plus ou moins
disponibles puissent se relayer sur les
compétences du conseil national il ya eu
peu de rectification mais l'assemblée a
été amené à retirer la proposition que
je vous avais fait et donc je reconnais
qu'elle était encore incertaine de
permettre au conseil national se
prononcer sur les amendements en cours
de discussion parlementaire parce que
les collègues députés ont été
impressionnés par le risque que cette
consultation à chaud avec en quelque
sorte du conseil national pendant une
discussion parlementaire alors que nous
savons tous que nous pouvons les uns les
autres et gouvernement le premier déposé
des amendements pour un examen très très
imminente
donc il apparu à l'assemblée que la
combinaison entre cette procédure
consultative et le déroulement de la vie
parlementaire était peu praticables je
vous propose en effet d'y renoncer
ce que j'ajoute simplement c'est que
lorsque ça se produit rarement mais ça
peut se produire un amendement à l'issue
pour essayer de tirer la synthèse d'une
discussion législative complexe peut
représenter une charge normative
nouvelle importante rien n'interdira son
auteur et notamment si ces gouvernements
de consulter volontairement sans
obligation
le conseil national pourra en avoir le
coeur net entre guillemets pour avoir la
vision des meilleurs experts pour savoir
si le dispositif proposé est praticable
donc il me semble qu'on peut faire
accord sur cette renonciation
en ce qui concerne j'ajoute une chose
nous avons un peu hésité de le texte
était un parfait en ce qui concerne les
blackos juridique de saisine d'un texte
nous avons opté l'assemblée opté pour
l'expression un texte qui présente un
impact technique et financier pour les
collectivités territoriales se sont ce
ces textes là qui devront
obligatoirement être soumis à des faux
seins faux de 2,2 d'irrégularités au
conseil national
je souhaite exprimer en m'appesantis ont
un peu que lorsque nous écrivons un
impact technique et financier ça ne
signifie pas que chaque disposition doit
avoir un impact à la fois techniques et
financiers mais que sur l'ensemble du
texte
on doit constater qu'il y a soit un
impact technique dans certaines
dispositions soient l'impact financier
dans l'aude
non ce n'est pas cumulatif mais c'est
donc les conditions de saisine les plus
larges et je crois qu'il y avait accord
en particulier avec les services du
gouvernement qui suivait la
l'élaboration du texte les les
conditions de saisine
on peut changer toutefois le l'assemblée
n'a pas retenu la saisine possible par
un président de groupe parlementaire
parce qu'ils ont considéré qu'il y avait
suffisamment de possibilités soit pour
les parlementaires eux mêmes soit pour
les différentes formations politiques
qui seront toutes représentées à
l'intérieur du conseil national de faire
appel à celui ci sans avoir à demander
l'autorisation à un partenaire politique
là les conditions de procédures du
conseil national ont fait également
l'objet de quelques modifications
de même la règle de publicité
l'assemblée a relevé à juste titre que
notre exigence que la publicité se fasse
par l'assertion journal officiel était
un peu datés puisqu'aujourd'hui la
publication la publicité de prise de
position d'un service ou d'une
institution administrative peut se
passer par de multiples autres canaux et
l'essentiel est que le public ou les
publics intéressés connaissent en temps
utile les avis du conseil national
et puis encore deux choses là
l'assemblée était plus rigoureuse que
nous et à mon avis à juste titre en dix
ans nous sommes d'accord puisque le
conseil national va être maintenant à
côté du comité des finances locales et
plus en son sein donc nous avions
autorisé le conseil national a voté son
propre budget et à se donner des
ressources prises sur la base de la dgf
parce que nous savions bien que ses
membres en feraient un usage
on ne peut plus modérée l'assemblée
était plus rue greuze en disant écoutez
seul le conseil le comité des finances
locales à un droit évidemment lié à ça à
sa mission même de d'opérer un
prélèvement pour son fonctionnement au
sein de la masse de la dgf donc si il y
a besoin de ressources propres pour cela
le conseil national d'évaluation des
normes et bien ça sera le codes comité
des finances locales qu'il approuvera je
crois que c'était plus cohérent que
notre position enfin dernière
modification significative c'est un
sujet dont nous avons les uns les autres
beaucoup parler en ce qui concerne les
normes sportives comme l'a dit madame la
ministre
alain sens un décret a instauré une
procédure spécifique est assez
protectrices à notre avis des
préoccupations des collectivités
territoriales à décret du 4 avril 2013
qui prévoit donc que les représentants
des collectivités territoriales au sein
du conseil national du sport pourront
s'adresser aux os et nationale de
l'évaluation des normes pour s'assurer
du caractère acceptable non d'une d'une
norme sportif donc nous avons
satisfaction par cette nouvelle
procédure
l'assemblée en a tiré les conséquences
sur la proposition du gouvernement
voilà donc tous les motifs qui ont
conduit sur vos positions la commission
des lois à prévoir l'adoption conforme
de cette proposition doit si bien qu' il
n'y aurait plus qu'à procéder
aux preuves aux formalités pour son
entrée en vigueur il y avait donc comme
la ministre également très très
judicieusement rappelé une petite
faiblesse juridique dans le fait que la
l'approbation ou non par le conseil
national d'un projet de loi n'était pas
rigoureusement attaché à l'adoption de
ce projet de loi par le gouvernement
puis par les assemblées et donc c'est là
c'est la raison pour laquelle les deux
auteurs de la proposition noir bien
voulu après le débat de première
instance déposé une proposition de loi
organique et se borne à prévoir que dans
l'étude d'impact laquelle ma vertu de la
loi organique de 2009 doit figurer dans
le dossier du projet de loi adopté par
le conseil des ministres et par le
conseil d'état et bien que dans ce
dossier de dévaluation de deux études
d'impact directement si dur le l'avis du
conseil national d'évaluation des normes
cette loi de 2009 et une loi organique
il fallait donc une proposition de loi
organique pour la compléter de ces
quelques mots c'est donc celle qui sera
également soumise à votre vote à
l'instant la commission lui a bien sûr
donné un avis favorable
je termine mes chers collègues et madame
la ministre en soulignant que c'est un
travail que nous avons mené en
collaboration particulièrement agréable
et constructive avec le gouvernement car
pendant que nous travaillons nous mêmes
à la suite de beaucoup de doléances de
nos mandants et beaucoup d'expérience
difficile sur la surcharge législatives
le gouvernement faisait son propre
parcours et il faut souligner en
particulier l'engagement personnel très
forts du premier ministre sur ce sujet
qu'il a manifesté tous les diverses
formes
nous avons des ministres qui sont tout à
fait convaincu du bien fondé de ce
projet un prémisse qui a d'ailleurs
spécifiquement organiser la structure
actuelle du secrétariat général du
gouvernement pour que nous ayons au sein
de
comment dire de la matrice de la
production juridique de l'état des
partenaires dédiés à cette recherche de
ceux de simplification je crois que nous
partons dans sous de bons auspices il me
reste simplement puisque je parlais du
rôle du gouvernement et sa bénévoles ans
à ce que le décret en conseil d'état
dont nous avons besoin pour l'entrée en
vigueur définitive du conseil national
de l'évolution des normes ne nous fasse
pas trop attendre madame la ministre
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à madame jacqueline gourault
coauteur de la proposition de loi
organique
bonjour madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi donc portant
création d'un conseil national
d'évaluation des normes applicables aux
collectivités territoriales et à leurs
établissements publics arrivent au sénat
pour sa deuxième lecture après des
ajustements en première lecture au sénat
et à l'assemblée nationale que vient de
détailler le rapporteur il
inutile de dire que c'est une grande
satisfaction que madame la ministre que
de voir aujourd'hui cette lecture sur
cette ppl que j'ai eu l'honneur de
déposer avec le président de la
commission des lois et j'espère je le
dis d'emblée que mes collègues mes
collègues pardon votre ongle conforme
cette phase est loi puisque ceci
permettra de mettre rapidement en forme
je dirais ce conseil national je dirais
nous sommes presque en famille là on
n'est pas très nombreux mais c'est
important parce qu'il y à aussi tous
ceux qui ont travaillé sur ce sur ce
point je voudrais saluer ici la présence
d'éric doligé qui a fait aussi un
important travail relatif à la
simplification du fonctionnement des
collectivités territoriales ces lois ont
été votées aussi bien au sénat qu'à
l'assemblée nationale et le processus
législatif doit encore repasser à
l'assemblée nationale pour une deuxième
lecture
merci de tout le travail puisque tout ce
qui a été fait sous la mandature
précédente et celle ci est bien a fait
prendre je dirais d'une manière générale
conscience de la gravité de la situation
et vous vous rappelez que l'année
dernière il ya un an ici aux états
généraux
du sénat des collectivités territoriales
eh bien ça a été un des points majeurs
qui a été discuté avec les élus locaux
qui était venu ici au sénat pour revenir
à notre proposition de loi si celle ci a
été provisoirement intégrée dans le
projet de loi affirmations des
métropoles dont nous allons débattre
d'ailleurs à la suite elle est soumise
de nouveau vote du sénat par souci
d'efficacité
en effet si les sénateurs votre conforme
ce texte la loi programme pourra comme
je les ai dit tout à l'heure prendre
effet immédiat immédiatement et je crois
que nous avons eu raison d'ailleurs de
faire cela ce que les événements de fin
de semaine dernière nous ont montré que
par exemple au sénat le haut conseil des
territoires avaient été passées par
pertes et profits
donc je crois que nous avons bien fait
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois et le rapporteur de la loi
métropole qui est aussi présent de faire
passer cette ppl ici en deuxième lecture
au sénat
nous arrivons enfin à la clôture d'une
première étape celle de la volonté de
changer notre production normative et de
mettre en place un nouveau dispositif de
contrôle et d'évaluation des normes
en effet le conseil national jeu
j'abrège le nom 1 est attendue par tout
le monde je dirais par les collectivités
locales par le législateur qui veut voir
m se mettre en place ce conseil national
et bien sûr par l'état qui est convaincu
de limiter le flux des normes est décidé
à faire évoluer ses pratiques et a
suscité une mobilisation à toutes les
étapes du processus de production des
normes
je souhaite aussi citer dans cette
assemblée monsieur alain lambert et jean
claude boulard dans le rapport de la
mission de lutte contre l'inflation
normative remis le 26 mars dernier
rapport à ces décoiffant d'ailleurs si
vous l'avez
regardez et je voudrais citer quelques
phrases du rapport qui sont tout à fait
révélatrice j'ouvre les guillemets le
moment est venu de rompre avec une
évolution qui conduit à la paralysie
ce moment et pertinents alors que les
moyens financiers des collectivités
locales vont diminuer la préservation de
leurs marges d'action implique un
allègement des charges et des délais
normatif qui leur sont imposées le
moment est décisif aussi pour les
acteurs économiques afin de libérer leur
force d'initiative d'innovation et de
création de richesses
je crois que cette phrase de jean claude
boulard et alain lambert est tout à fait
révélatrice on voit d'ailleurs les
prémices d'une nouvelle appréhension de
la question l'impact du premier prix
d'énormes absurde de rapport lambert
boulard en particulier l'arrêté
saucisses qui est l'arrêté du 30
septembre 2011 définit des finissants
l'équilibré nutritionnel en restauration
scolaire a été au fond une image qui a
beaucoup frappé et j'ai pu constater que
le ministère de l'agriculture a le 3
septembre longuement lister tous les
bienfaits apportés par la réglementation
afin avant pardon de rappeler que
conformément aux décisions du comité
interministériel pour la modernisation
de l'action publique du 2 avril dernier
une évaluation sera réalisée afin de
décider de l'opportunité de la
suppression ou de l'allègement de
l'ensemble des normes identifiés dans ce
rapport donc on voit bien là que l'idée
commence à s'installer qu'il faut
absolument faire quelque chose par
ailleurs le jeudi 18 juillet 2013 le
premier ministre en place le moratoire
sur les normes applicables aux
collectivités territoriales qui s'est
révélé peu efficaces par un gel de la
réglementation à compter du 1er
septembre pour toute nouvelle norme une
norme ancien devra être supprimés ou
allégées par ailleurs
il limite le nombre et la longueur des
circulaires ministérielles au delà de
l'institution de ce gel le premier
ministre a proposé d'améliorer
l'évaluation par l'administration de
l'impact juridique et financier des
projets textes réglementaires qu'elle
élabore le pouvoir réglementaire devra
donc également respecter un principe de
proportionnalité en s'efforçant de
laisser des marges de manoeuvre pour la
mise en oeuvre ou prévoir des modalités
d'adaptation aux situations
particulières
je cite bien sûr là cette race
enfin le coût des normes sera rendu
public tous les six mois et un premier
bilan en sera fait au 1er janvier 2014
je ne vais pas revenir sur la
proposition de loi organique n'est sur
le détail de ce qui a été voté par les
députés puisque le rapporteur vient de
le faire très très précisément je dirais
simplement que pour terminer cette
intervention que la délégation
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation que j'ai l'honneur de
présider invité la semaine dernière la
commission consultative d'évaluation des
normes la ccn
l'organisme qui existent actuellement à
tenir l'une de cette réunion chez nous
au sénat en notre présence
nous avons pu mesurer plusieurs choses
le tourner vers mon collègue devant
hervé qui étaient présents nous avons pu
mesurer que c'était un travail assez
fastidieux et qu' il faut je dirais que
des spécialistes et des juristes pour
siéger dans cette ce conseil d'autre
part il faut de la disponibilité et met
tout à l'heure alain richard l'a rappelé
dans une démesure qui a été prise et
puis enfin je voudrais saluer le travail
d'alain lambert
parce que je vous assure qu'il fait un
énorme travail avec beaucoup de patience
de conviction et d'autorité et donc
je voulais le préciser la deuxième chose
que je voulais vous dire c'est trois
dossiers ont été traités parmi lesquels
la modification d'un arrêté de 2010 sur
l'accessibilité des bâtiments
d'habitation d'habitation temporaire ou
saisonnière comme les logements
étudiants et le gouvernement propose des
changements et de dire que seuls 5 % de
ces bâtiments devraient être accessibles
bien sûr la ccn a donné un avis
favorable
et cela va dans le bon sens comme quoi
les choses sur le plan réglementaire
peuvent bouger et c'est très important
parce que c'est un sujet l'accessibilité
qui est beaucoup
je dirais dans les têtes puisque
l'échéance de 2015 arrive prochainement
je voudrais aussi signaler enfin que
madame verreault directrice chargé de la
simplification placé auprès du
secrétariat général du gouvernement nous
a présenté la manière dont le
gouvernement allait traiter les stocks
et il est clair que le secrétariat
général du gouvernement et la futur cnn
vont travailler très étroitement ce sera
l'outil bien sûr pour mettre en place
cette simplification des stocks mais
madame verreault a proposé aussi qu'une
commission comme la délégation
collectivités territoriales soit associé
à cette étude des stocks je crois que
c'est très important et monsieur boulard
et monsieur lambert ont d'ailleurs sans
cesse soulevé l'idée que le sénat devait
être particulièrement associée à cette
démarche comme le souhaitait le
président du sénat et président de la
république vous en souvenez l'année
dernière aux assises eh bien je dirais
qu'avec tout ce que je viens de vous
dire je ne peux mes chers collègues que
souhaiter que vous ayez l'idée de voter
conforme
ces textes pour que tout se mette en
place
extrêmement rapidement et je crois que
c'est attendu par beaucoup d'élus ça je
suis allée justement samedi matin
remplacer jacques pélissard président de
l'association des maires de france au
congrès départemental des maires de la
sarthe
et bien il y à des sujets dont j'ai
beaucoup en parlent entendu parler il y
en a 3 3 je vais vous n'allez pas être
surpris les rythmes scolaires
bien sûr le paie lui le plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal et
troisièmement les normes
je vous remercie merci madame gouro la
parole est à monsieur jean pierre sueur
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
beaucoup de collègues et d'élus se sont
penchés sur cette question des normes et
si nous pouvons espérer aboutir cet
après midi au vote d'un texte
je crois qu'il faut rappeler mais cela a
été excellemment bien fait par madame la
ministre par monsieur le rapporteur
alain richard par jacqueline gourault
présidente de la délégation aux
collectivités à l'instant si bien que je
me bornerai à dire que précieux fut
l'implication de jacqueline gourault
après les états généraux dont
l'initiative revient à notre président
jean pierre bel que précieux fut le
travail accompli par alain lambert qui a
fait des rapports extrêmement précis je
pense au dernier d'entre eux il ya
beaucoup travailler eux à jean claude
boulard aussi qui a travaillé en lien
avec lui-même à eric doligé qui a
présenté une proposition de loi qui
était antérieure à la présente
proposition de loi ou plutôt au présente
proposition de loi est aussi aux états
généraux proposition de loi sur laquelle
nous avons travaillé qui est
actuellement à l'assemblée nationale et
qui je l'espère reviendra ici de manière
à ce qu'elle puisse être adoptée et que
l'on dispose d'un ensemble cohérent et
riche par rapport à cette question qui
est une préoccupation constante des 550
mille élus locaux que compte notre
république
la question n'est pas facile et il ne
faut pas la simplifier parce que nous
avons tous besoin de normes et souvent
nous demandons davantage de normes
davantage de règles davantage de loi
puisque finalement aucune société
humaine ne peut bien fonctionner sans
règles il y a le moment où l'abondance
de normes fini par se retourner contre
le désir de règles et aboutit à une
sorte de paralysie ou d'embolie et on
nous demande qu'il y ait moins de normes
alors nous sommes dans cet entre deux
dans ce paradoxe est l'une des grandes
heures si je puis dire de notre mission
et que cela soit dit avec la modestie
nécessaire c'est de faire des lois
justes
c'est à dire des lois utile nécessaire
et non superfétatoire surabondante et
l'une de nos missions est de veiller à
ce que les décrets les arrêter les
circulaires puisque notre rôle consiste
aussi à contrôler le gouvernement soit
juste qu'il y en ait suffisamment
qu'elle soit là et qu'elle arrive à
l'heure dite
lorsqu'elles sont nécessaires mais qu'il
n'y ait pas d'embolie de surabondance
qui aboutissent à des effets contraires
donc ce que nous recherchons c'est la
justesse
c'est le bon équilibre le bon point
d'équilibré à cet égard nous avons
beaucoup travaillé et je dois dire
monsieur le rapporteur l'a dit que nos
collègues députés ont aussi bien
travaillé puisque aujourd'hui notre
rapporteur nous propose de voter le
texte de l'assemblée nationale conforme
et cette bonne coopération avec les
députés est précieuse
j'espère qu'on pourra par elle à voir
prospérer à nouveau sur d'autres textes
je pense à celui dont nous allons parler
dans quelques temps quelques moments sur
les métropoles les l'action publique
territoriale je vois que monsieur val
d'irène donc c'est préparer tout durant
les derniers jours pour affronter la
dernière la dernière partie du débat
c'est vrai que nous sommes heureux je
crois pouvoir le dire quand nous voyons
article après article qu il va
probablement y avoir un texte du sénat
qui permettra à un dialogue extrêmement
fructueux avec nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale toujours est il
que cette instance conseil national
d'évaluation des normes ne sera pas une
instance en plus d'abord parce qu'elle
se substitue à une autre qui existent
mais surtout elle aura un rôle très
précieux qui sera de travailler en amont
n'ont pas protesté après méconnaître au
moment où la décision est prise
le problème qui se pose mais anticiper
prévenir en amont faire en sorte que
tout projet de loi passe par le filtre
de cette instance qu'il ne sera pas
pléthorique mais il y aura des élus
locaux des représentants de l'état qui
émettront un avis et qui pourront
d'ailleurs sollicité des réécriture du
texte je pense que c'est une bonne façon
de fonctionner et je terminerai en
soulignant l'importance de la seconde du
second projet de loi
que nous avons fait avec madame de la
seconde proposition de loi que nous
avons écrites avec madame jacqueline
gourault suit d'ailleurs à une remarque
de notre collègue anna richard lors de
la lecture précédente
en effet eux vous avez fait observer à
très juste titre que s'il y avait
désormais des études d'impact innovation
sur lequel dont il faudra un jour faire
d'ailleurs l'évaluation le bilan s'il ya
des études d'impact jointe au projet de
loi c'est parce que une loi organique à
fixer cela conformément à la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
par conséquent si l'on veut que les avis
de la commission nationale d'évaluation
des normes soit dans le fascicule même
où figurera le projet de loi il faut une
loi organique pour simplement énoncé
cela mais ce faisant nous posons un acte
dont les conséquences seront très loin
d'être négligeable pourquoi parce que si
la commission nationale d'évaluation des
normes dit voilà cette idée de tels
fédérations sportives parfaitement
d'estimables mais de demander que toutes
les installations de tous les terrains
homologués dans toutes les communes de
france soit revu un coût excessif
eu égard à l'intérêt qu'elle présente eh
bien ce ne sera pas une vague
déclaration perdu dans des monceaux de
papier non tout parlementaire tous les
parlementaires disposeront en même temps
que du projet de loi
de l'avis motivé de la commission
nationale et il sera impossible à un
député ou un sénateur quel qu'il soit
d'ignorer qu'une instance composée
largement d'élus locaux et de
représentants de l'état aura considéré
que la dépense est taxé 6
eu égard à l'intérêt de la mesure nous
verrons quelles seront les conséquences
de cette innovation
mais je crois que c'est une véritable
innovation et que c'est un progrès de
méthode pour éviter de pleurer sur les
excès des normes et bien nous prévoyons
une mesure très précise efficace pour
prévenir les excès il est toujours mieux
d'anticiper que de dénoncer a posteriori
en tout cas je termine en remerciant
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont bien
voulu contribuer depuis les états
généraux des collectivités locales et
même avant et après à la publication à
l'élaboration plutôt deux ces deux
propositions de loi je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite de la discussion générale commune
la parole est à madame hélène lipietz
pour le groupe écologie
il
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je croyais que le cumul des
mandats devait permettre aux
collectivités territoriales d'être
présentés lorsqu'on parlait d'elle or
nous revoilà devant la tentative de
limiter l'étranglement des collectivités
territoriales par les normes et nous ne
sommes que 12
mais heureusement les meilleurs en
première lecture les écologistes avaient
proposé un amendement demandant qu'à
toute norme créer une autre soit
supprimé la proposition nous revient
l'assemblée nationale avec une avancée
le conseil national d'évaluation des
normes pourra se saisir et proposé
l'abrogation de normes devenu obsolète
mais si j'ai bien compris le
gouvernement pense aller un peu plus
loin si j'ai compris votre discours
c'est une avancée certaine et un espoir
de désengorgement des collectivités
territoriales toutefois une fois de plus
nous législateurs avons raté le coche
d'une opportunité peu révolutionnaire
pourtant mais qui aurait été efficace
en effet les câbles énorme épée toriques
à ce jour nous en sommes tous d'accord
et nous sommes tous d'accord sur
l'impératif de diminuer leurs noms et
les simplifier mais comment suivre les
écologistes qui proposait supprimer
normes à chacune créé aurait au moins
permis de figer leur nombre ne laissait
au conseil la possibilité de proposer
des abrogations n'arrêtera pas
l'inflation reste donc plus qu'à espérer
que le conseil national prendre à coeur
d'abroger le maximum de noms obsolète
si j'avais proposé et cet amendement ce
n'est pas parce que les normes doivent
être normativement renouvelé j'ai déjà
dit mon ami mon admiration pour de
vieilles lois qui n'ont pas pris une
ride
certainement parce qu'elles sont simples
de lecture directe et qu'elles sont
adaptables à l'évolution de la société
je suis donc pour un droit flexible et
non pour un droit rigide
vous remarquerez d'ailleurs que notre
président de la commission des lois est
notre présidente de la délégation
sénatoriale aux collectivités toria de
crétins y aller la décentralisation
n'ont pas proposé de simplifier le droit
mais de simplifier les normes peut-être
parce que justement nous ne savons plus
créer le droit trouver la quintessence
de la règle
minimales communes au jeu sociétal qui
nous permettrait de vivre ensemble de
faire société et de faire nation nos
lois sont trop compliquées vautrot dans
le détail et en jeune parlementaire je
cède à cette manie tout comme les plus
aguerris de notre assemblée
mais peut-être parce que nous avons plus
le temps de faire simple de faire court
comme disait un nommé rédacteur en chef
corrigeant mes articles de plus nous
faisons temps de loi que nous mais ne
connaissons plus les normes que nous
éditons ainsi pour ceux qui ont suivi la
saga de mes amendements pollution mine
lumineuse et métropole savez vous que ni
monsieur le rapporteur ni madame la
ministre ne m'ont donné la bonne réponse
la lutte contre la pollution lumineuse
de lorraine ne relève pas de décret et
ne doit pas faire l'objet d'un texte à
intervenir
la prévention des nuisances lumineuses
relève encore moins d'un détail comme
les fientes de pigeons comme le pensait
monsieur collomb bas depuis une loi du
12 juillet 2010 prises en application du
grenelle 2 en son article soit 173
encore une loi fleuve codifié à
l'article l7 183,3 de l'environnement
dit que d'environnement
c'est le maire qui est chargée du site
du contrôle du respect des dispositions
prévues au 1 de l'article l 583 200 fois
les installations communales défini
selon leur puissance lumineuse total
application zone équipements pour les
quêtes seront le contrôle relève de la
compétence de l'état
fermez les guillemets les dispositions
de l'article l 583 deux bogeys bulli qui
sont juste au-dessus tienne sodi ligne
et renvoie une partie réglementaire qui
elle doit tenir sur dix pages
enfin j'exagère n'aurait-elle pas été
plus simple de prévoir que le nord que
le maire doit respecter et faire
respecter une norme maximale des
missions en luxe par mètre carré
cette émission étant fixée par décret y
compris pour sa propre commune notamment
concernant l'éclairage de voirie ce
pouvoir pouvant faire l'objet comme je
proposais ils le proposent toujours dans
mes amendement sur la loi de
modernisation de l'action publique d'un
chef de file à ou d'une compétence délai
gable et c'est ainsi que je propose la
suppression d'une première nomme
obsolète tous ces articles 581 2 et
suivants que je propose donc la
suppression d'une première nomme
obsolète mois de trois ans après sa
création et que je fais gagner du temps
un autre assemblée sur les 260
amendements restant à discuter
cet après midi ce soir et cette nuit je
vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
monsieur eric doligé pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président la commission des
lois et madame et monsieur le co auteur
du texte des textes pardon donc mes
chers collègues
d'abord je voudrais dire amicalement
madame lipietz que la bce soit quand
même rectifié que le fait de la présence
n'est pas lié au cumul ou au non cumul
sinon je constaterai que tous les
membres de votre groupe cumule
puisqu'ils sont tous absents à part vous
donc vous voyez comme quoi le cumul
n'est pas forcément une raison
d'absences et qu'il ya beaucoup de
collègues ici qui ont d'autres fonctions
et qui sont présents bien donc le texte
que nous allons revoir aujourd'hui est
un texte fort simple puisqu'il consiste
à créer un conseil national à définir sa
composition et ses missions nos
collègues jacqueline gourault et jean
pierre sueur ont déposé les premiers
éléments le 12 novembre 2012
il ya près d'un an et il a fallu tout ce
temps ou qu'il nous revienne en deuxième
lecture après avoir été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale avec quelques
modifications
je me permets d'insister sur ce marathon
puisqu'il s'agit d'un texte qui porte
sur la création d'un conseil national
d'évaluation des normes applicables aux
collectivités territoriales et leurs
établissements publics
nous sommes un certain nombre chercher
par tous les moyens à simplifier le
président sarkozy courant 2011 avait
lancé la machine à simplifier le
président hollande un courant 2012 fait
part lors des états généraux de sa
volonté d'aller vite et il a pris un
certain nombre de
disposition nous voyons bien que la
complexité de notre système ne permet
pas de mettre facilement en musique les
paroles la simplification consiste à
réduire les délais à supprimer les
textes superflu à éviter que la
contrainte nouvelle sera supérieur à
l'avantagé retirer à vérifier si le
texte nouveau n'existe pas déjà sous une
autre forme au niveau national ou s'il
n'est pas supérieur un texte européen
mais cela consiste également un pouvoir
expérimenter sous certaines conditions
pour obtenir une réponse à ces questions
il faut mettre en place une structure
nouvelle qui est un pouvoir certain mais
qui sera malheureusement relatif
il faut que ce pouvoir soit reconnue ce
cheminement d'une année du présent texte
nous sommes pas encore tout à fait au
bout du chemin démontre s'il en était
besoin la complicité d'un autre
fonctionnement en raison de normes
administratives résultant de notre
constitution qui au fil du temps est
devenue de plus en plus normatives mais
aussi de nos règles internes pour des
textes majeurs très complexes tels notre
organisation territoriale applicable en
2010 c'est que nous travaillons dans
l'urgence et pour les textes simples et
maintenant de nous a semblé nous devons
subir le parcours du combattant alors
que là il y a urgence à agir et à
simplifier la raison aurait voulu qu'en
trois mois une telle proposition qui ne
rencontre pas d'obstacles majeurs puisse
être appliquée par ailleurs pour
complexifier un peu la donne il a été
nécessaire de nous soumettre en
procédure accélérée une ppl organique
afin de pouvoir renforcer les avis du
conseil national d'évaluation des normes
voilà vous avez pu suivre bien sûr
l'examen de la proposition de loi sur
l'application des normes aux
collectivités locales
nous y revenons à 19h dans 24heures
sénat et ce soir à 22h avec sonia
mabrouk